[Müzik]
arkadaşlarım geldiklerinde böyle bir
daveti yaptıklarında hocam dediler
konumuz fikir fikirle beraber eylemin
oluşması ve
sonuç noktasında etkinin nasıl olacağını
tartışmak istiyoruz bu toplantılarda
dediler ben de aklıma gelen bazı şeyleri
not
etmiştim o meseleleri de analiz ederiz
diye
düşündüm fikir olarak değerlendirdiğimiz
sevgili
katılımcılar reel manada üç kategoride
değerlendirilmesini Ben doğru buluyorum
bir bunu mikro alemde kendi içimizde
değerlendirebiliriz bir normo alemde
yakın çevremizde değerlendirebiliriz Bir
de Makro alemde dünya ölçeğinde belki
saman yolu ölçeğinde uzay ölçeğinde
değerlendirebiliriz Tabii kendi
fikirlerimiz kendi dünyamızı yansıtır
yakın birliktelikler imiz beraber
hareket ettiğimiz sonuçları yansıtır
Makro dediğimiz bütün dünyadan
etkilenerek oluşan fikirlerimiz de Makro
dünyamızı
yansıtır Tabii ki bunlar çocuklukta
başka gençlikte başka orta yaşta başka
ileri yaşta başka her dönemde de
farklılaşır ve şunu iyi bilelim ki bizim
çocukluktan itibaren
hayallerimizle gerçek hayatta
yaşadıklarımız hep ters orantılıdır
sevgili katılımcılar Ben çocukken 3-4
yaşındayken o zamanlar çok Televizyon
yoktu ama işte belli Demek ki eve gelen
gazetelerden veya farklı şeylerden Bir
Uzay gemim olsun istiyordum yaşım
büyüdükçe ilkokulda bir tıra indim Sonra
işte ortaokula doğru spor arabalar çok
ilgimizi çekiyordu televizyonlar
başladı Ondan sonra üniv üniteyi
bitirdik ya acaba işte bir dört teker
üstünde giden araba olur mu falan ama
hiçbiri olmadı sadece bisikletim vardı
çocukken şimdi arabam var yine ters ol
anılıyor fakat bisikletim yok şimdi de
dolayısıyla çocukluktaki sizin
hayalleriniz değerlendirmeleriniz le şu
andaki bundan sonraki süreçlerde
değerlendirmeleriniz hep ters orantılı
olacak şimdiye kadar mikro olarak kendi
zihnimizde belli şeyleri
değerlendirmeleri konuştuk norm Alem
olarak da değerlendireceğim Yakın
çevremiz aile çevremiz arkadaş çevremiz
okul çevremiz ve beraber
değerlendirmelerimiz olacak sevgili
arkadaşlar ve psikososyoloji etkileşim
dediğimiz etkileşimin başladığı nokta da
aslında Burası kendi mikro fikirlerimiz
mikro değerlendirmelerimiz le henüz
psikososyoloji
etkileşim
başlamıyor ve o etkileşimle aile
etkileşim kardeşlerimiz annemiz babamız
ninemiz büyüklerimiz okul çevremiz bir
psikososyoloji etkileşimler imiz oluyor
burada bakıyorum kız öğrenciler daha
fazla belki organizatörler kız olduğu
için kızları daha çok çağırmış
herhalde ne oluyor kızlarda Tabii
kadınlar kızlar daha duygusal daha hissi
Erkekler biraz daha belki skor olarak
yüzde kaç bilmiyorum da ama en az 51 49
gibi daha reall bu sefer arkadaşlarda
işte bir kısım arkadaşlar in oluyor bir
kısım arkadaşlar out oluyor bir kısım
kanki oluyor bir kısmı Kanki olmuyor
kızlar Çabuk küsüyor çabuk barışıyor
erkekler küserse zor barışıyor biraz
daha zaman alıyor işte bunlar sosyal
etkileşim etkileşim olarak sevgili
arkadaşlar
başlıyor ve bu etkileşimde normal olarak
değerlendirdiğimiz etkileşimde çok
önemli olan bir nokta var artık birlikte
belli şeylere karar veriyoruz Bir gün
oturuyoruz Ortaokulu bitiriyoruz liseye
gideceğiz ailemizle anne babamızla
bizden büyük a beyimiz varsa a beyimiz
ablamız da karar veriyoruz şu liseye
gidelim yani bir istişare mekanizması
başlıyor
artık Birlikte karar verme mekanizması
başlıyor sevgili arkadaşlar
arkadaşlarınız da istişare ediyorsunuz
belletmenler le öğretmenleriniz de
istişare ediyorsunuz buna Biz ne diyoruz
terminolojide istişari Biraz daha
Osmanlıca bir tabir ortak akıla müracaat
ediyorsunuz bakın bir filozofun dediğini
çok önemsiyorum hayatımda da yapmaya
çalışıyorum ortak akılla
beraberce yaptığım yanlışları şahsi
olarak verdiğim doğru kararlara tercih
ederim diyor filozofun birisi bütün
hayatın ızda da size bunu
öneriyorum fikir
planında bir miktar mikro alemi konuştuk
bir miktar norm alemi konuştuk Makro
Alem olarak değerlendirdiğimiz dünyadaki
hadiselerin basın yoluyla gazete yoluyla
görsel medya yoluyla veya kitaplar
aracılığıyla zihnimize yerleşmesi var ve
oradan fikir ETK etkileşim var sevgili
arkadaşlar saygıdeğer hocalarım burada
önemli olan çok önemli bir parametre var
ama çok önemli bir parametre var
Dışarıdan gelen bu etkiler her bir
erlerimiz
için pozitif Sonuçlar da doğurabilir
maalesef negatif Sonuçlar da doğurabilir
işte onun için çok çok sağlam
süzgeçleme çok iyi bir
süzgeçle içinize almanız lazım ve bunu
realize etmeniz lazım ha hocam Mehmet
Bey bu Süzgeç nasıl olur derseniz Bence
bu süzgeci anaokuluna ve Hatta ve
hatta çok daha küçük yaşlardan
başladığını kabul etmemiz gerekiyor
Anaokulundan şu andaki Bulunduğunuz
eğitim konumunuza kadar hangi
konumdaysa
üniversitede iseniz üniversitede
üniversiteyi bitirmiş eğitmenden en
sondaki akademik noktanı kadar bu Süzgeç
her gün recheck yani tekrar Check edip
değerlendirmeniz lazım bu süzgeçin
başlangıcını şuna kadar inebilirsiniz 34
yaşında ninemizin dizine yatıp
dinlediğimiz masallara kadar
indirebilirsiniz oradaki Dinlediğiniz
masallar sizin fikir olgunlaşmanın da
etkisi olduğuna inanıyorum ve ben
hatırlıyorum babaannemle ve dedemle
büyüdüm çok pozitif etkileri olduğunu
hayatımda hep Hatırlıyorum belki hayal
meyal hatırlıyorum bazı şeyleri ama o
süzgeçin oluşmaya başlamasında onları
hep rahmetle anıyorum
işte dış faktörlerden gelen
etkileşimlerin realiteler Zin içinize
gelm oturması için de o Süzgeç her gün
tekrar ayarını yapmanız lazım İstem
olmaması gereken reel olmayan
kavramların içinize girmesine engel
olacaksınız sevgili
arkadaşlar şayet hakiki manada o süzgeci
çalıştırmazsak işte maalesef Yakın
tarihte yaşadığımız veya tarihi
kitaplardan okuduğumuz sonu izmle biten
sonu istle biten bu akımlara kapılan
binlerce
milyonlarca insanı görebilirsiniz
hangisi doğruydu hangisi yanlıştı bunun
ikisini birbirinden ayırt edememiş
oluruz
Arkadaşlar biraz önce size
normo alemdeki istişari bir meseleden
bahsettim ortak akıla müracaattan
bahsettim sevgili arkadaşlar kendi
hayatımda yaşadığım kendi mesleki
hayatımda kariyer hayatımda
yaşadığım birkaç
örnekle neden Fikri olarak Eee şahsi
değerlendirme yapmayıp ortak akıla
müracaat edip hangi pozitif sonuçlara
ulaştığım bir iki örnekle sizinle
paylaşmak istiyorum yaklaşık bundan 10
yıl kadar önce belki 11 12 yıl kadar
önce Amerika'ya eğitim için gitmiştim
Eee önce
yazıştık bulunduğum
klinikte oradaki hocayla
yazıştık Belli bir zaman sonra cevap
geldi ve çalışmaya gittim ben İtalyan
asıllı bir hoca Joseph kelli denen bir
adam dünyada aur cerrahisinin Yani bizim
meslekteki argo tabirle babalarından
birisi dünyada bu ameliyatları en fazla
yapan adam bir adam daha var o da Eee
Irak asıllı bir zat O da Profesör Hazım
Safi Fakat ben bu adama 6 ay yaklaşık
yazıştığım hatırlıyorum zinhar bir
cevabı sevap alamadım herhalde bizi
böyle Onlara göre mi değerlendirdiler Ne
yaptılar burkin faso'nun en köşe
bucaklar andaki bir köydeki kalp
merkezinden email gönderiyor olarak
değerlendirdiler herhalde sekreter a ası
bir cevap vermedi aynı
şehirdir Yaklaşık 700 800 metre mesafede
iki tane klinik Ben Eee birinci hocayla
işte koseli ile çalışmaya başladım
çalışmamın sonuna doğru artık Eee
programım bitecek E tabii o Öbür hoca da
dünyada babalardan birisi O biraz daha
beyin damarlarını içine alan arkus la
ilgileniyor Ben de onu çok önemsiyorum
yine zinhan randevu alamadık maalesef
adam çok meşgul herhalde Sonra bir gün
sabah yaydık randevu mandu alamadık
Çatkapı gidelim Ne yapalım Yapacak bir
şey yok Ben de çok arzu ediyorum
Amerika'dan da hemen dönmek istemiyorum
programım diğer Hocanın yanında
programım bitiyor Arkadaşlar dostlar da
var
houston'da
Beraber konuşuyoruz Ben dedim ki sabah
Bismillah mesaiye başladığında gideyim
kapıyı çalayım selam aleyküm selam Ben
böyleyim Sizinle çalışmak istiyorum
diyeyim
dedim sonra
eee Mustafa Bey vardı dostum orada
e araştırma rç laboratuvarında çalışan
bir arkadaşımız ya Mehmet hocam dedi bak
ben Cerrah olduğum halde bir istişareyi
paylaştığımı anlatıyorum bu şahsi
Fikrimde Mehmet hocam dedi bu cerrahlar
dedi sabah çok
dedi Eşref saatlerinde olmazlar öbür
saati söylemiyorum siz biliyorsunuz ne
saat olduğunu çok Eşref saatlerinde
olmazlar kafalarında hep problemler var
işte ameliyata girecekler sonuçlarına
bakarlar falan daha relx bir zamanda
gidelim buna böyle işte ofisine
geçtiğinde 2.5 3 gibi gidelim
falan baktım çok mantıklı söylüyor
Mustafa Bey doğru şimdi bakıyorum
Hakikaten ben Kendi hayatıma bazen
yönetici arkadaşlarımızla da
paylaştığımız oluyor Aman diyorum
arkadaşlara söyleyin bana Eşref saatimde
gelsinler olacak iş olmuyor çünkü öbür
saatte geldiklerinde maalesef Hepimiz
insanız hepimizin etkileşimi etkilenimi
var sevgili
arkadaşlar sonra hakikaten Mustafa
Bey'in dediği gibi gittik bir istişare
ettik yani ortak akıla müracaat ettik
ve beraber değerlendirdik bir Cuma
günüydü hiç unutmuyorum
Eee metodist Cuma bir mescit var cuma
namazını kıldık saat işte 22.30 kahveyi
mahve içtik Biraz kafayı toparlayalım
diye gittik ofisine gittik Üç Arkadaş
Ankara'dan bir hocamız vardı o da o
zaman hüstın daydı beraberiz şimdi
kardiyoloji kürsü başkanı Beyhan hoca
Mustafa Bey
ben ben de artık üzülüyorum program
bitti ayrılacağım randevuda alamamış çok
arzu ediyorum adamla çalışmayı gittik
Çatkapı saat 2.3 gibi üçümüz beraber
kapıya da bir sekreteryası var selam
verdik sekreter hanıma
Biz
dedik 15.000 K öteden geliyoruz aynı
kültürlerin insanıyız Irak asıllı
olduğunu biliyorum Hazım safi'nin
5 dakika görüşmek istiyoruz Şimdi kadın
çok ters baktı bize sekreter Hanım
randevunuz var mı dedi yok dedik randevu
mandu yok dedi Niye geldiniz ki buraya
dedi randevunuz yoksa dedi Kusura
bakmayın dedi randevusuz dedi kimse
görüşemez Tamam dedik biz uğraştık
randevu almak için mail yazdık şunu
yaptık bunu yaptık falan dedi Çok özür
diliyorum şu anda dedi
hoca doçentleri le profesörlerle beraber
bir toplantıda zaten bu
imkansız sonra Mustafa beyle göz göze
geldik göz teması Beyhan beyle göz göze
geldik dedik vallahi Yapacak bir şey yok
biz bu fırsatı kaçırmak
istemiyoruz hafif boynu sağa çevirip 40
derece bir açıyla biraz Mazlum ifadeyle
dedik Sadece 5
dakika kadın biraz yumuşar gibi oldu
sekreter hanımefendi bir dakika dedi Siz
bir oturun ha Sonra dedim ki
Eee yanımda dedim Profesör de var bakın
dedim Beyhan bey de Kadir Bey gibi öyle
çok yaşını belli etmeyen çok minyon
tipli bir Eee arkadaşımız Hatta ben ona
bazen Latife yapıyorum yani lacivert
ceketi giydir gri pantolu giydir lise
4'e kayd ettirebilirsin arkadaşı öyle
bir yapıda bir
arkadaşımız küçük bir pusula yazdı kadın
şeye verdi toplantı odasına
verdi biraz ümitlendim Alal acle kadın
heyecanla bizi çağırdı Buyurun dedi hoca
sizi çağırıyor dedi Gittik kapıda
kapıdan çıkmış toplantısını terk etmiş
küçük bir toplantı salonu kapıya çıktı
biz hemen
gittik Merhaba dedik tanıştık adamın ilk
lafı şu oldu I an otom dedi ben
osmanlıyım dedi adam biz de Boş Durur
muyuz vom dedik Biz de
osmanlıyız benden ne istiyorsunuz dedi
arkadaşlar dedi Ben de aslında benim
çalıştığım hocayla da
eski böyle bir frotmanı var Çok rahat
değiller Onun kıdemlisi ben mertçe
dna'larına bakabilir Kadir Bey yalan
söylemeden DNA izi yalan izi bırakmadan
mertçe dedim ki ben hocam dedim kiyle
çalışıyorum programım bitiyor Sizin de
deneyiminizi görmek istiyorum
dedim tam Bana ismimi söyledikten sonra
senin ismin altında dedi Muhammed dedi
sen bundan sonra Muhammed'i kullan dedi
ben sana Muhammed diyeceğim dedi Tamam
dedim pazartesi sabah dedi O gün Cuma
Pazartesi sabah Dedi 07.30'da yoğun
bakım kapısında ol
dedi Allah Allah toplam 5 dakika geçti
bütün bu Ahval 5 dakika
geçti Eee ben şaşırdım Amerika'da çok
önemlidir yani Kimliksiz mimiksiz işte
bir yere giremezsin kartlar kapıları
açacak falan ya diim Ben pazartesi
7.30'a Nereye gideceğim Nasıl olacak
bayağı endişeliyim dedim ki çok özür
dilerim dedim Benim dedim kimlik kartım
yok şu yok bu yok o süreçlerde 3 be gün
sürüyor birkaç günde alıyorsunuz kimlik
kartınızı adam şunu dedi if Someone ask
you dedi yani Birisi sana bir şey
sorarsa şunu diyebilirsin you can Say
dedi
ders dedi ben D safin arkadaşıyım dersin
dedi ve bakın sabah 88'de gitseydik
nokta nokta saatine denk gelseydik
hocanın bu belki
olmayacaktı ve gerçekten çok istifade
ettiğimiz bir hocamızı sonra çok
görüştük adamla ama her Aort cerrahi
kongresine gittiğimizde birçok kere
görüştük Ondan sonrasında
gittim ayrıldık sonra 2006'da programım
bitti Döndüm Türkiye'ye bulunduğum
hastaneye çalıştığım hastaneye döndüm
tekrar New York'taki aur cerrahi
Kongresi'ne gittiğimizde koridorda
gidiyorum arkamdan bir ses yankılandı
Muhammed diye falan ya dedim ben
Muhammed değilim ama bu sesi
tanıyorum döndüm o dedi Muhammed
nasılsın dedi doktor Safi gel dedi
hüsten dedi dönelim Beraber seninle iyi
çalışıyorduk dedi Ha özür dilerim önce
dedi did you so kurish problem dedi Kürt
problemini çözdünüz mü dedi Ben dedim
not yet
çalışıyoruz trying dedim gel dedi hsta
dönelim dedi beraber iyi çalışıyorduk
dedi Ben de ona dedim ki sizin
deneyiminizi gördükten sonra dedim
Türkiye'nin bana ihtiyacı var dedim
böyle Latife
olarak çok hoşuna gitti hala görüşüyoruz
çok daha yeni gittik Hüsün ziyaretimizde
başka randevularım da vardı adam bizi
bırakmıyor odasından şimdi talebelerimiz
arkadaşlarımızı uzmanlarımız
gönderiyoruz ve sadece ve sadece 15
Saniyelik bir istişareyle onlarca
arkadaş kazanmış olduk sevgili
arkadaşlar fikirleriniz bir şahsi
fikirleriniz bir yakın çevreden
etkilendiğiniz fikirleriniz Bir de Makro
alemde etkilendiğiniz fikirleriniz kendi
fikirleriniz ne olursa olsun acele karar
vermeyin biraz daha eni konu karar verin
eskilerin Benim babaannemin tabiriyle 1
2 ortak akıldan hiçbir zaman
vazgeçmeyin her kararınızı tekrar çek
edin üç etkiye ulaşmada Makro Alem
olarak değerlendirdiğiniz dış etkilerde
kesinlikle ve kesinlikle kendi s
süzgecin ii oluşturun ve her şeyi
içinize alırken o süzgeçten geçirin
sevgili arkadaşlar Tekrar bana Vakit
ayırdığınız için çok teşekkür
ediyorum